-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
This is it.
You guys, everyone is excited.
This Sunday is Super Bowl LVII,
between the Kansas City Chiefs
and the Philadelphia Eagles.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
[Indistinct]
Yep, the players have dreamed
of this their whole lives
and, this weekend,
they finally get to see Rihanna.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
That's right.
Rihanna said that she's been
so focused on the show, that she
forgot about Valentine's Day.
[ Awws and laughter ]
Yeah, and you know a bunch
of guys
are going to now use
that excuse.
[ Laughter ]
Like, "Oh, I forgot about it
because I was so focused
on Rihanna's halftime show."
[ Laughter ]
This year's Super Bowl will be
watched in 180 countries.
-Wow!
-Well, 179,
now that we took out
the Chinese spy balloon.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They will not be wa--
They won't be watching.
I love everything about the
Super Bowl, especially the food.
You know you ate too much when
you arrive in an Eagles jersey
and leave in an Eagles crop top.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I'm saying?
[ Applause ]
We all overdo it
at Super Bowl parties,
but the best way
to curb your appetite?
Just watch your uncle sucking
a wing bone for the first half.
[ Laughter ]
"Alright, hey, good, alright.
Come on, you did enough there,
alright? Yeah.
-Ooh.
-Yeah, alright. Yep, yep, yep.
There's nothing left --
-[ Smacking lips ]
-There's nothing left on that.
Hey, come on!"
[ Laughter ]
-[ Pop ]
-Unfortunately,
due to inflation, everybody --
I forgot to tell
everyone this --
seven-layer dip's now been
cut back to three layers.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-I'm sorry.
Yeah, the Super Bowl
can be hard.
We drink all day,
but can't go to the bathroom
during the game, halftime,
or commercials.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, fans of both teams
will be tailgating.
It's the one time you see
a bunch of people outside a van
and think,
"Yeah, I should go over there.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, what's up, guys?"
And get this -- First Lady
and Philadelphia Eagles fan
Jill Biden
is attending the Super Bowl.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Yeah.
First, the Grammys;
now, the Super Bowl.
Who knew Jill would be living
the same life as Rihanna?
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's amazing.
Yep, Jill gets to see Rihanna
perform at halftime.
Meanwhile, Joe's first halftime
show was Beethoven.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Di di di da.
-Mozart.
-Mozart was better.
Mozart was better.
Switching gears --
I read that Mike Pence
was just subpoenaed
by the special counsel
investigating Trump's role
in the January 6th attack.
-Ooh.
-Yeah, if that wasn't
bad enough,
Pence fainted when he heard
the word subpoena.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sting plays ]
And finally, today,
"Magic Mike's Last Dance"
hit theaters.
-Whoa.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Jill Biden was like,
"I will also be attending that."